if you just post something on a video to
talk about something that's going on in
business that's fine if you take a
headline from your own article you then
take that article and you take it into a
green screen on social and you talk over
it that format will get you three four
five times more viewers it's strategic
organic content joining me today is Gary
vaynerchuk who is a Serial entrepreneur
and serves as the chairman of media
conglomerate Vayner X the CEO of media
agency vaynermedia and a Creator and CEO
of nft project be friends he's also the
co-founder of Rezi which he sold to
American Express in 2019 and as an angel
investor to some companies you may have
heard of like Facebook Twitter and
Snapchat you may have seen them as
garyvee online where he documents his
life as a CEO on social media where he
has more than 44 million followers
across various platforms Gary hi welcome
to Abu Dhabi thanks for being here
thanks for having me thanks for talking
to me so that was a lot in their media
social media nfts just at the top I
would have talked to you about all of
those things but I kind of just want to
get the sense that you're thinking these
days on the state of just consumer
culture yeah the head of media agency
consumer culture is your bread and
butter what are people wanting these
days
I mean there's so many things I think
our hypothesis my hypothesis has always
been based on context and relevance over
awareness
of awareness meaning
you know you could know that Coca-Cola
exists but can Coca-Cola get you to care
and so what I think in Fortune 500 land
Starbucks Nikes BMW I think a lot about
this question from the context of
consumers want relevance
you know they want to see something from
these brands that makes them feel
something or consider them at a small
business and Creator level it's the same
we build Our Brands and our awareness
from relevance we're unable to run a
Super Bowl commercial so we have to win
on the Battle of putting out 40 50
pieces of social media content a day
across seven or eight different
platforms so that's what I think people
are looking for so to win it involves
prodigious output
free content if you're small and
it's about relevance but when you talk
about output on social media where are
you seeing companies actually getting it
wrong
you know I would argue the bigger the
company the more wrong they are right
um it just is the hot take all right
that's a headline what are some examples
that you're seeing well I would tell you
that you know again to put into context
for the listeners vaynerx vaynermedia my
marketing company we work globally APAC
uh Europe latam us
um we're we're recording here in the
Middle East not for kicks and Giggles
we'll be here and we'll be in Africa and
we'll be in Brazil will be everywhere
and when I look at around the world what
happens is the bigger you are the more
you treat social media the way you
treated television and billboards and
print and what's happening is it's just
all vanilla and there's not enough
output so what are companies getting
wrong they don't have enough output they
don't live under the context of
strategic content they just post for the
sake of posting they don't factor in
what is our religion which is something
we call pack platforms and culture if
you don't know that Carousel ads are
over indexing right on right now on
Instagram you're not going to post them
so if you don't know the platforms the
out not just the algorithm that
everybody likes to talk about but even
ones
ability to take advantage of all the
different creative formats a green
screen right in your line of work if you
just post something on a video to talk
about something that's going on in
business that's fine if you take a
headline from your own article you write
an article you then take that article
and you take it into a green screen on
social and you talk over it I'm sure
everybody who's listening right now if
they have social media have seen a human
talk over a green screen of an article
that format will get you three four five
times more viewers at the end it's
strategic organic content what we call
sock is the biggest elephant in the room
right now so where do influencers play
into this conversation in terms of
output and content where is the content
coming from well to even add to that
I'll answer that but where influencers
are playing a role is they're the ones
who are more native to understanding the
creative strategy they have no choice
they don't honor day copywriter they're
the modern day where do they fit into
the agent
oh well they to me they're competitive
to the agency model they're additive to
the agency model they are the future
agency owners that's what I came from I
was making wine content today we are
going to visit the wonderful and
interesting world of Pinot Grigio and
realize this actually scales for every
business in the world let me start an
agency vaynermedia is literally besides
widening Kennedy the largest global
independent agency that's been created
in the last 40 years that came from a
content creator that's who I was yes I
was a retailer yes I was an e-commerce
retailer but at the end of the day the
only reason I parade into Madison Avenue
was because I spent a half a decade
winning on content and was realizing it
was outperforming my print radio direct
mail and television advertising and so
how is content evolving so when I was I
actually my first job out of college was
at an ad agency
separate story but it was the time of
native advertising inbound marketing we
were on the HubSpot DNA yes the word
early client of HubSpot and um talking
about just generating this death by
content well awesome website build as
much articles win SEO have them come to
you so where are we now the social media
version apt in the conversation where is
this where are we going well that's a
different thing but to I'll answer both
of those one we are in the social media
version of what the website version of
inbound marketing was 15 years ago so it
is a volume game but you know you
probably learned this at the time I
don't know how long you were there but
what people learned in writing SEO and
articles was yes it'd be awesome if you
wrote 50 but it'd be a heck of a lot
better if you wrote 13 great ones than
50 bad ones right when I say make a lot
of content if you make 13 horrible
pieces of social media content there's
only so much good that can come of that
right it's better than one horrible
piece of content but the reality is you
have to be good at it as far as chat GPD
is we are in the pre-dawn of scaled AI
making a huge impact on copy and
creative I think for us personally at
Vayner and me personally the trademark
and copyright aspect of all of this is a
very big elephant in the room and so we
can't use it yet for our clients if God
forbid there's a lawsuit and the
creative kid you know so we have to be
careful really cite your sources you
can't you can't
and and what a lot of people in your
line of work are worried about is it's
an it's a new Google all over again
right it's going to index everything and
take it for itself and not create any
economics or cite any credit to the
sources this is a major major Hornet's
Nest that's going to be figured out
probably over the next five to 15 years
but the reality is the technology is not
going back in the Genie bottle this is
here and it will be here I think it
actually is going to collide quite a bit
with uh decentralized servers yeah I
want to pump the brakes on decentralized
for one second because I want to talk to
you the last time the national spoke to
you it was on nfts yes and it does feel
like the shine the bloom is off the rose
on NFC South by Southwest was last week
yes uh talking Tech and culture yes and
if Keys won't really mentioned meta just
made headlines they're shuttering their
nft efforts
be friends is your effort in this space
yes
what are you thinking you know I'm
thinking what I thought nine months ago
when I made 50 to 100 pieces of content
that said 99 of these things are going
to go to zero because what happened was
what happened with late 90s
internet stocks
then there then they were stocks this
time they were Collectibles but the same
thing happened everyone got way too gold
rushy everybody cared about greed
instead of building and you had way too
much hysteria and so what you had was a
scenario that was inevitable which was
the macro technology is profound
I'm more bullish on nfts today than I
was a year ago
but the individual projects that were
built a year ago were built for
short-term financial reasons not for
long-term reality so for me
when I built v-friends almost two years
ago I'm like I'm gonna build Pokemon
meet Sesame Street and this is going to
take me the rest of my life
I think that that's a very different
point of view on it so that that was my
take I think the really interesting part
is smart contract
I think decentralized servers that
create Providence are going to become a
very important element in an AI world I
think I'm hearing your uh your wine
Heritage meeting up with you or it's
true your blockchain that's a very smart
inheritance that's a very smart
observation the provenance thing really
matters it's like Vineyard Source it's I
learned a lot in the wine business that
ironically impacts creating value a
hundred percent so value in the wine
world is all about provenance it's all
about the year the timeliness
when you look at things like nfts you do
think you can create value by
being able to cite with but really
strong Fidelity where something comes
from only if people want to yeah like
what people don't understand is only one
percent of comic books are sought after
only one percent of sports cards are
sought after only one percent of
sneakers are sought after so when humans
collect they only collect a very small
subset of the overall genre
so art
is no different than nfts sports cards
are no different than nfts Comics are no
different than nfts the problem was last
year people clumped nfts as all nfts
that would be like saying every piece of
art is going to go up in value
instead of just Jackson Pollock and Andy
Warhol so yes I believe that nfts are
going to be a collectible in perpetuity
because I know how people collect it's
already clear and by the way in this
huge winter that is so atrocity and like
it's all over there's a normity of
collectible going on there's an enormity
of money being pushed and by the way SVP
Bank goes down and look what happens
people take a step back and say huh
maybe something that's decentralized
that can't be you know impacted is
something I may want to look at and so
you know I think there's still a lot of
change and things to think through but
what happened
was super predictable and I'm not Monday
morning quarterbacking at the height of
it
in August and September I went on a
rampage to make sure that people were
being thoughtful and unfortunately
people are real you know we're at a real
estate conference right now it happens
in real estate it happens on Wall Street
it happens in Collectibles when it's
going good people become delusional and
greedy and that's just human nature so
you predict it will be durable
yeah it's like this day a hundred
percent but again the oh of course the
macro technology is profound when
everybody wrote articles that the
internet was a fad in 2000 because all
the stocks collapsed because they were
overvalued by Wall Street that didn't
make the internet less important that
Wall Street was greedy today the same
thing's happening with nfts so you like
to dispense advice so I want to ask you
if you're into dispense advice now on
the nft chat GPT metaverse this kind of
space of Frontier technology and you're
a small business owner what moves what
what are the smart moves right now in
these spaces is it smart to move in
these
as an SMB probably not other than
education you know you have to be very
thoughtful with your monies when you're
an SMB and so first of all it goes back
to the first part of the conversation
what every small business on Earth from
every corner of the earth needs to
figure out is a very smart organic
social media strategy it is
disproportionately the biggest impact on
their bottom line when it comes to at
least marketing and demand creation as
far as Frontier attack it's good to keep
an eye on it it's good to be ready it's
good to flirt with it education is very
powerful so I think people should know
about it but I think Frontier Tech is
something that is incredibly high risk
more importantly it's never at the scale
that people want it to be but it's
important to pay attention and get your
hands dirty in it so you are prepared
sometimes I think about okay uh this
shoshana zuba book surveillance
capitalism kind of coin that term this
idea of the attention economy the
infinite scroll we kind of all find
ourselves in you're a real creature of
the infinite scroll you you live and die
yes by by that how do you stay I think
the other side of the coin on
this social media economy that we've
built is surveillance capitalism is this
kind of Darker more nefarious way of
thinking about it and there are real
privacy concerns in like societal
implications I guess what I want to ask
you is how do you stay
motivated in that space do you ever have
second thoughts on where we're headed I
stay motivated because I'm incredibly
optimistic on the human race
I I think that you don't look at
internet culture and think oh my gosh
yikes you're you're a big celebrant of
it I'm much more excited about it than
what happened pre-internet culture like
you know I think what's important is to
understand what are we demonizing and
what are we scared of so to me privacy
is controllable
so like if somebody's listening right
now and they're like I'm really no way
Gary you're so wrong I'm like delete the
apps
don't have an iPhone
like I love the concept of
accountability
like an opt-in or opto but it's becoming
decreasingly possible to opt out as
you're making this I would actually
argue the other way I think there's
micro trends of people opting out more
than ever I think it was harder seven
years ago to opt out than today I think
it's cooler to opt out now I think
people are leaning into knowing their
options and I think people are finding
their calibration of balance like the
amount of parents that like stop me in
the middle screen saying Tick Tock and
I'm like then delete it off your kid's
phone like the lack of accountability
and the lack of understanding how much
control humans actually have I think
people have absolutely opted in to this
depressive state that America or China
or Tick Tock or meta or Mark Zuckerberg
controls them I I think it's a cop-out I
think it's because accountability has
come out of favor and I don't I'm not
worried about it at all not worried
about it okay so last question
dispensing advice to people can I add
one point yeah it would be the same you
know there was a there's a couple other
things I think a lot about I think about
America Banning alcohol
they thought that that would solve the
problem
like to me Banning or stopping or being
scared is never the problem it's
understanding how to use everything a
car is dangerous if you don't know how
to use it
a bottle of gin is dangerous if you
don't know how to use it sugar is
dangerous if you don't know how to use
it I think we need education and
conversation but I think ultimately it's
about accountability do you bear
responsibility to do more education on
these things or does that is that a
space somebody else should occupy
you know I I think I do it all the time
I'm doing it right now with you yeah but
my problem is that most people
ride waves so hard that I'm doing it
right now I think I'm when I'm answering
hey have you ever considered
accountability I think I'm doing way
more public service right now than
saying we should ban this and we should
ban that this is a major pandemic of the
last 30 years the world has fallen in
love with pointing fingers it's your
fault your media it's my fault I'm
social media why are we not into thumbs
well my my question really was how do
you stay motivated in a landscape that's
that's yelling at you until and pointing
fingers how do you stay how do you get
up every morning and kind of get back
get back on the horse because I have no
attachment to the validation and or the
tearing down
see one of the great things when you
don't believe in your own headlines is
you don't believe in the trolling either
when you were actually in a state of
doing things for yourself and what makes
you happy not the addiction of the
validation of the likes or the treachery
of being torn down you're in a much
better place I'm motivated because I'm
detached
right a stoic a stoic life depend on it
I don't know if I believe you that
you're detached well I think that's only
because you don't know me yeah you know
and which I respect it's one of the
reasons I judge no one I don't know them
garyvee want to talk to you so much fun
you know it's funny you you we end with
that it's been the biggest thing of like
how to your point like how does one
sustain when there's so much going on
it's you know for me it's
um that whole validation or Detachment
it's kind of like my sports teams I like
love the process of a team winning a
championship yeah but once they do I'm
like out
and so like when the Yankees and the
Rangers won their championships I
stopped cheering for them and I never
understood it when I was a kid but as
I've gotten older I'm like ah
[Music]
it's fun for me the winning the wins and
the losses you need to feel yeah just I
just like that I like the trying yeah
more than like the outcome well I mean I
asked you guys
what I cover
so I'm the future editor at the national
which means I cover
yeah and I find that the more I find out
about this
I think that I think I get that what I
will tell you and this maybe will help
you like get less stunting is like go
read the articles about things that see
Monday now go read what they said about
the television I was gonna be a zombie
machine right it will start to feel more
charming and less Sinister and nefarious
it's it's only because the in the we're
in the moment now where people are
demonizing technology yeah you know 10
years ago when you were working at up
like that was the Golden Era that was
all good
and now we're in the all bad and the
reality is it's always in the middle
yeah I don't know I do think the visuals
that we're using now are so much bigger
and more sophisticated and are creating
a feedback loop
to you know but but you'll appreciate
this everything's a feedback loop Vogue
magazine was a feedback loop in 1987.
hmm it was
you know like I think I think that what
we we struggle with is understanding
that within context everything is that
like you know yeah everything is forming
opinion Walter Cronkite dictated what
people thought at scale
it's really interesting when you really
like dig into this game it's fascinating
yeah I just I don't know I think it's
capacity to manipulate
but your mom was manipulating you before
right like I get it like okay but like
we have always been manipulated by
whatever we were consuming
and so the question is is it better that
it's the world or is it just a small
group of people and that's always been
the case Yeah the more things change the
more they stay the same of course yeah
yeah awesome thank you so much thanks
for being an inspiration thank you oh my
gosh
I'm very humble thank you thank you
cheers
foreign